mesdames et messieurs bonsoir avant que
je vous développe les autres titres de
l'actualité sachez qu'en ce moment même
le président carter a réuni à washington
son conseil de sécurité qui doit d'un
instant à l'autre prendre d'importantes
décisions concernant des sanctions
contre l'iran en effet l'administration
carter a appris avec stupéfaction que
l'ayatollah khomeiny avait décidé que
les otages resteraient aux mains des
étudiants islamiques jusqu'à la réunion
du parlement fin mai prochain donc tout
espoir de voir libérer les otages à
l'ambassade américaine
ou tout au moins de voir leur sort
immédiat s'améliorer n'existe plus il se
pourrait que d'ici la fin de cette
édition nous sachions quel décision
monsieur carter a pris en tous les cas
cette décision de l'ayatollah khomeini
de ne rien changer à leur sort est une
défaite morale et politique pour le
président de la république monsieur
manie sabres qui donnait l'impression
depuis quelques jours d'avoir obtenu une
amélioration importante de la situation
des étudiants
on peut craindre de plus en plus que les
otages qui sont retenus depuis plus de
cinq mois n'en est encore pour de
longues semaines
autre raison de préoccupations pour
l'iran la tension avec son voisin et
l'irak les forces armées iraniennes et
des gardiens de la révolution ont été
mises en alerte
teheran considérant comme un ultimatum
de l'irak
le fait que celui ci exige le retrait
immédiat des forces iraniennes des 3 in
située à l'entrée du détroit d'ormuz il
que les forces du shah avait occupé fin
lorsque les britanniques ray tirèrent
leur éléments militaires du golfe baisse
à cuba il ya maintenant près de dix
mille réfugiés un passé dans les locaux
et les jardins de l'ambassade du pérou à
la havane ils attendent la possibilité
de partir pour le pérou c'est à dire
qu'on leur donne un visa d'entrée au
pérou en effet fidel castro changeant
brusquement d'altitude a annoncé il ya
48 heures que désormais tout pub 1 qui
souhaitait quitter son pays et est
parfaitement libre de le faire mais
encore faut-il que les candidats au
départ obtiennent un visa pour pouvoir
entrer dans le pays où ils veulent se
rendre et c'est l'attitude nouvelles de
fidel castro qui a motivé la plus
formidable de cumin vers l'ambassade
péruvienne alors celle-ci surprise par
le flot de gens n'est pas en mesure de
les ravitailler l'ambassade attend la
réponse du pérou même
pour accorder ou pour refuser les visas
en tout cas des 10000 cuba entassés et
qui veulent fuir illustre la difficulté
de l'existence quotidienne à cuba après
plus de vingt ans de castrisme et
doivent leur fidel castro l'homme qui
lie à 20 ans devant des foules en délire
avaient promis aux cubains
l'établissement d'un socialisme dans la
jourre président aujourd'hui du
mouvement des non-alignés un des leaders
du tiers-monde
on ne peut plus cacher depuis 48 heures
l'échec d'un régime qui n'aura fait que
se dégrader au fil des années
l'essentiel de l'aide extérieure
soviétique pourtant renouvelé
régulièrement ne suffit plus à masquer
les problèmes économiques manque de
prévision échec de tous les plans à
court ou long terme
malade d'une bureaucratie totalement
inefficace les cubains eux mêmes ont
sans doute contribué à cet échec
refusant le travail par embrigadement
programmée par le gouvernement
en vingt ans la production de canne à
sucre est devenu presque inexistante les
autocritiques des responsable cubain de
fidel castro lui-même ne semble rien
avoir changé l'instauration de cartes de
rationnement n'a fait qu'aggraver le
mécontentement d'une population déjà
singulièrement traumatisés par les
atteintes aux libertés
depuis deux ans dans les prisons de la
vanne de simples délinquants
intellectuelle ou opposants ont pris la
place des prisonniers politiques dans
les mêmes proportions
et si dans les premières années du
régime de fidel castro
ce sont surtout des familles de classe
moyenne qui ont quitté le pays
aujourd'hui ce sont de simples cubains
sont venus s'entasser dans les locaux de
l'ambassade du pérou à la havane
il ne s'agit plus d'une fuite devant le
régime communiste s'est maintenant
l'exode pure et simple d'une partie de
la population cubaine
en israël la nuit dernière à un commando
de fedayins à pénétrer dans le kibboutz
de miss gaffe âmes située au nord-est de
la galilée le commando venaient du sud
liban il a pris en otage des femmes et
des enfants dans un local où résident
des bébés de moins d'un an
les autorités israéliennes ont été très
fermes comme toujours elles ont fait
donner l'assaut contre les cinq fedayin
qui ont été tués un adulte et un bébé
ont été également tués parmi les civils
du kibboutz et 11 soldats de l'armée
israélienne ont été blessés au cours de
l'assaut qu'ils venaient au commando
dont le fl a le front de libération
arabe a revendiqué l'action
le kibboutz de miss gave am la
forteresse du peuple en hébreu n'a pu
empêcher l'opération du commando suicide
palestiniens
les cinq fedayin avait traversé à la
faveur de la nuit les lignes de barbelés
qui sépare le liban d'israël malgré les
mesures de sécurité exceptionnelles
prises à l'occasion des fêtes de pâques
ils ont alors occupé le centre d'enfants
le commando voulait en effet obtenir la
libération d'une cinquantaine de
militants palestiniens en prisonnier
mais l'armée israélienne a pris
l'habitude de ne pas négocier dans ce
genre de prise d'otages l'assaut a été
donné deux heures plus tard les cinq
membres du commando a battu un homme et
un enfant tués dans la fusillade et une
quinzaine de soldats israéliens blessés
dont l'un devait mourir dans la soirée
les fedayin se réclamait du front de
libération arabe d'obédience irakienne
qui voulait ainsi marquer le 33ème
anniversaire de la fondation du parti
baas au pouvoir à bagdad et prouver
qu'il n'ya pas de frontière sûre pour
israël c'est la première fois depuis
plus d'un an
depuis la taxe d'un autobus sur la route
haifa tel aviv cas commando palestinien
parvient à réaliser une prise d'otages
après avoir traversé la frontière
israélienne
l'opération a mobilisé plusieurs
centaines de soldats et l'on s'attendait
ce soir à des opérations de représailles
de l'armée israélienne contre les camps
palestiniens du
liban
c'est dans ce contexte dramatique pour
israël que s'ouvre demain à washington
la rencontre entre les présidents salle
avec artère vous savez que selon les
accords de camp david signés entre
messieurs carter sadate et begin
c'est la date du 26 mai qui est le jour
limite pour trouver une solution à la
question de l'autonomie palestinienne en
cisjordanie et à gaza mais il paraît
pratiquement certain paul nahon que
cette date du 26 mai ne pourra pas être
respecté
cette fois anouar el sadate et menahem
begin iront séparément washington est en
principe pas de sommet prévu à trois
avec le président carter vous savez que
les négociations entre l'egypte et
israël piétine depuis de longs mois et
but bien sûr sur l'éternel problème
palestinien
on devait se mettre d'accord sur une
formule d'autonomie avant le 26 mai
prochain mais anouar el sadate a affirmé
que cette date pourrait être repoussée à
condition bien sûr que le gouvernement
israélien fasse preuve de bonne volonté
avant de partir pour washington le
président égyptien a fait une
proposition il suggère que le régime
d'autonomie soit appliqué d'abord à
jérusalem est et au territoire de gaza
on verra ensuite pour la cisjordanie
en fait il est peu probable que monsieur
begin accepte une partition de la ville
sainte
mais tout se passe un peu comme si le
président sadate avait décidé d'adopter
la position la plus souple possible pour
démontrer
deux choses la première que le
gouvernement égyptien est prêt à toutes
les concessions raisonnable seconde
chose après les dix mois négociations
entre israël et l'egypte
sadate veut prouver que c'est le premier
ministre d'israël monsieur ménard nb
guînes et lui seul qui fait obstacle à
la paix en réaffirmant sans cesse le
droit pour les juifs de s'implanter où
bon leur semble en israël allusion
directe bien sûr aux colonies sauvages
de cisjordanie le président carter est
en pleine campagne électorale il doit
absolument faire pression sur les deux
camps pour obtenir pour consolider un de
ces unique succès de politique étrangère
avec en toile de fond aussi le rôle que
peut éventuellement jouer l'europe au
proche orient si une solution n'était
pas trouvée rapidement
le cessez-le-feu qui vient d'être
conclue au tchad grâce aux bons offices
du président du togo le général eyadéma
entrera en vigueur demain midi mais le
chef de l'état tchadien monsieur
goukouni dans les hommes se battent
contre les partisans 10e navré mais
guère optimiste sur ce nouvel accord
hier encore les combattants s'affrontent
à l'armé lourde dans les rues de la
capitale des chaque jour la base
française djamena située pourtant à
l'écart des combats est un peu plus
menacé comme on peut le constater nos
envoyés spéciaux patrick clément et
jacques douay
ces obus explosent à quelques centaines
de mètres seulement du périmètre de la
base française y amène à chaque jour
presque une centaine d'obus sont tirées
par les partisans d'hissène habré ou
ceux du coup ni chaque jour les
parachutistes français sont encore un
peu plus coincé par ces tirs qui pour la
plupart sont totalement approximatif
m post est tout à fait en bout de la
piste d'atterrissage pour en assurer sa
sécurité sont de plus en plus exposé la
situation de leur petit poste fabriquer
de sacs de sable doux à la jumelle ils
peuvent observer les combats ressemble
de plus en plus à celui d'un fort
chabrol
les officiers posté la tour de contrôle
qui ont en charge les atterrissages où
les décollages et transall et un
hélicoptère français surveille
constamment les abords de la piste qui
le jour en jour elle aussi est de moins
en moins sur cette base occupée par 11
cents parachutistes français est un
curieux mélange de démonstration de
force d'une part et de position mal
assuré d'autre part le meilleur exemple
en est cette jeep qui se permet d'aller
partout certes mais avec un drapeau
blanc qui rappelle sa neutralité
l'homme qui a la responsabilité de cette
présence française à n'djamena
le voici d'un colonel de légion il a 51
ans de l'indochine à djibouti il a tout
connu tout connu sauf une situation
comme celle ci où l'un de vos confrères
m'avait demandé de soleil l'attitude et
la mission défense française dans un
conflit armé entre les tendances et
j'avais répondu à cette époque que les
jours sereins j'observerai naturellement
une stricte neutralité et que ma mission
l'essentiel serait certainement
d'assurer la sauvegarde et l'évacuation
des ressortissants français habitant à
jeddah
cette mission de recueil des français de
leur évacuation a été pleinement assurée
par les forces que je commande mais si
on vous attaque et bien si on m'attaque
sur mon dispositif actuel c'est-à-dire
dans mes positions actuelles
je serai bien sûr amené à me défendre
par les armes mais auparavant et
j'essaierai naturellement la
conciliation avec les personnes qui
m'attaquent de façon à ne pas arriver à
l'emploi des arts et en cas de besoin
que j'utilisais maison comme on vient de
le voir la position du palais l'arbre y
ait de plus en plus difficiles entre les
deux parties qui s'affrontent
il est comme on dit dans le langage
courant assis entre deux chaises
il se contente d'être un arbitre est
cependant être arbitre on a une
politique celle de la france mais
bientôt il devra tenir compte des
exigences d'un problème personnage le
panel kamougué après il est navré 'après
coup' unis kamougué reprendre une force
important il ne se bat pas djamena mais
ces forces contrôlent complètement le
sud tchadien là-bas vivent encore 300
français ils n'ont pas été évacués
300 français il travaillait encore là
bas mais la sécurité n'est absolument
pas assuré
aucun soldat français la stationne dans
cette région alors va se poser le
problème de savoir comment justement
assurer la sécurité de ses 300 français
après les congés de pâques c'est à dire
dès demain vont reprendre les
négociations entre l'épiscopat français
et le vatican
et ce pour établir le programme exact de
la visite du pape jean paul ii je vous
rappelle que le souverain pontife sera à
paris et 31 mai 1er et 2 juin
l'annoncé officielle de ce séjour de
jean paul ii dans notre pays pourrait
avoir lieu dans les tout prochains jours
antenne 2 en tout cas fera un effort
exceptionnel pour vous permettre de
suivre le mieux possible cet événement
considérable que la visite du pape en
france dans un déjà sachez quand n2 vous
fera vivre en direct toutes les étapes
du séjour du saint-père la rédaction
d'antenne 2 et déjà mobilisés à cet
effet en mer du nord une nouvelle plate
forme nommée aymeric ipsen devait
remplacer l'avait xandre qui landes qui
avait sombré il ya une dizaine de jours
provoquant la catastrophe
donc vous vous souvenez or la nouvelle
plateforme amarrés dans le port de
d'avengers en attendant d'être amené en
pleine mer s'est incliné hier soir de 20
degrés cet incident heureusement pas
fait de victimes mais il cause une
grande inquiétude
jean jacques dufour
d'un seul coup hier quelques jours après
le drame de l'alexander qui landes
la plateforme henrik ibsen s'est incliné
à son tour de 20 degrés heureusement
l'incident n'est pas arrivé au large
mais dans le petit port de davantage rs
et sans dommage que les 60 ouvriers qui
travaillaient à bord ont pu être évacués
on imagine la même chose en pleine mer
par une nuit tempête erreur humaine
défaillance matérielle selon les
premiers éléments d'enquêté
il semblerait que le mauvais
fonctionnement d'une valve chargé de
contrôler l'entrée de l'eau qui sert de
ballast dans l'un des pieds de la plate
forme soit responsable de l'incident
les experts auront donc maintenant
inspecté deux plateformes hôtelière
celle ci qui vient de s'affaisser et
évidemment l'alexandrie landes qui
devrait être remorqué bientôt un
remorquage de plusieurs jours car le
derrick qui pointe maintenant vers le
bas obligera les remorqueurs à faire un
détour afin de ne pas endommager le
réseau de pipelines sous marins de la
mer du nord
washington 20 heures 10 une dépêche afp
le président carter à décider de
l'expulsion de tous les diplomates
iraniens aux états unis en raison de
l'absence de tout progrès dans la sphère
des otages de terrain apprend on de
sources officielles et des 20h13 je
pense qu'avant la fin de journal nous
aurons encore d'autres informations à ce
sujet le long week-end de pâques se
termine la circulation a été en général
assez fluide sur les routes de france
mais les retours on pay pay certainement
plus difficile dans les grandes villes
et surtout dans la capitale il y avait
énormément de monde avec un fort
pourcentage d'étrangers
réjouissons nous que les beautés de la
france attire toujours autant de
visiteurs d'autres pays
en bourgogne beaucoup de monde en alsace
aussi sur la côte d'azur on a affiché
complet presque partout il y avait
davantage de visiteurs que l'an passé
dans les stations des pyrénées et 3% de
plus de curistes à luchon mais j'y
reviens dans les grandes villes les
touristes ont pu circuler avec facilité
car jusqu au milieu de cet après midi il
n'y avait presque pas de voiture dans
paris par exemple les parisiens eux et
les français en général est temps
d'aller dépenser quelques litres de
super à 3,35 pour de longues promenades
ou pour la route des vacances
est ce que cette véritable ruée sur les
routes
le week-end n'est pas en contradiction
avec l'évolution économique je pense
notamment à la flambée des prix de
l'essence de la question pierre marie
tient mieux que je vous pose oui ça
dépend ce qu'on appelle une crise
économico au printemps en 1930 par
exemple vous pouvez être certain qu'il
n'y avait pas beaucoup new yorkais pour
partir en vacances pour la bonne raison
qu'ils étaient pour la plupart au
chômage
en ce moment dit merci ne connaissant
rien de tel en france nous avons un
million quatre cent mille demandeurs
d'emploi à peu près et c'est beaucoup
mais les restrictions de budget qui
impose beaucoup d'entre eux ne se
sentent pas tellement de la consommation
d'ensemble parce qu'il y à plus de 22
millions de gens qui travaillent et 54
millions qui consomment normalement en
revanche je suis me connesson en france
une forme de crise économique plus
insidieuse à savoir les prix augmentent
régulièrement un peu plus vite que les
salaires
et cela influe sûrement sur la
consommation mais laquelle à l'évidence
apparemment pour l'instant pas celle des
loisirs et de l'automobile ce week-end
vous l'avez dit les hôtels ont affiché
complet les autoroutes aussi et on sait
d'autre part que les ventes
d'automobiles marche bien alors est ce
que le pouvoir d'achat une tendance à la
baisse ou non oui un peu et un petit peu
plus pour les cadres
mais cette baisse se fait en ce moment à
l'intérieur d'une marge de sécurité
et cette marge de sécurité c'est l'
épargne si vous regardez les comptes des
caisses d'epargne anciennement vous
apercevez que si les français dépensent
toujours autant en revanche ils mettent
un peu moins d'argent de côté autrement
dit pour rester au même niveau dépenser
autant ils dépensent une partie de ce
qu'ils auraient dû économiser mais on ne
peut pas tirer éternellement sur ses
économies alors à quel prix de l'essence
à quel prix de l'automobile les français
laisseront ils leur voiture au garage
certains experts disent 4.5 franc
commence à voir les priorités de chacun
surtout dans un pays où les inégalités
de revenus sont si grandes ce qui est
sûr c'est pour les français abandonnent
massivement leurs vacances et leurs
chères voitures il faudrait qu'il n'est
plus le choix qu'on ait plus cette
possibilité de jouer sur cette marge de
sécurité de l' épargne et on en est pas
encore là passons aux sports football la
france a remporté le festival
international junior de came en battant
l'italie par 5 buts à 0
quant aux tirs c'est ma foi il y avait
je pense que nous y venons justement il
il y avait hier c'est à longchamp mais
d'abord le prix d'harcourt qui a vu la
rentrée de friteries case et vous voyez
que la jument qui a gagné deux prix de
l'arc de triomphe
l'année dernière qui appartient à madame
raid elle est entraînée par sa fille
cricket
elle est montée par son fils freddy ou
et que la jument gagne très facilement
tandis que le marmot lui ne finit que
troisième derrière genk et finit lui
deuxième qu'entre tiercé dans les images
vont venir
et bien il y avait un non partant le
numéro 3 ans tmx à 300 mètres de
l'arrivée et assez près de la corde
vous allez voir routier avec la casaque
jaune manche bleus de monsieur km de new
york
le cheval est monté par keith a cédé 1
freiné par ses cris le voici à pecs et
parma chérubin qui semble le dominer
mais routier après le premier poteau va
repartir en pleine piste il y aura un
léger incident à l'arrivée un léger
tassement chérubins sera rétrogradé
après enquête officielle et l'arrivée
sera de 7 14 9
c'est à dire routier ces écarts up
l'entraîneur du gagnant sécly avait déjà
gagné le prix du président de la
république que dimanche dernier
on vient nous avertir du pmu que les
rapports du tiercé avec un non partants
ne tomberai que à partir de 20h30 pas il
y a dix ans vie voire coûté 20 30 kg
aujourd'hui 600 francs vous imaginez la
spéculation en tanzanie la police a
arrêté trois suspects à la suite de la
découverte de plus de 1300 défenses
d'éléphants c'est-à-dire quelques 3
tonnes et demie d'ivoire enterré dans
une forêt du centre du pays ce
braconnage trafic de l'ivoire sont
monnaie courante dans de nombreuses
régions d'afrique
c'est au kenya que jean jacques dufour
s'est rendu pour faire son enquête
dans la brousse les braconniers les
trafiquants ne tue pas pour vivre eux
ils tuent pour s'enrichir un commerce
illicite qui a des conséquences graves
pour la faune certaines espèces sont en
voie d'extinction
ainsi en ces temps cent mille éléphants
ont été massacrés parce que ses défenses
d'ivoire
valls est 100 francs le kilo la
situation est encore plus grave pour les
rhinocéros chassés pour leur corne une
corde avec laquelle on fait des manches
de poignard au yémen du nord et des
préparations plus ou moins médicinales
ou aphrodisiaques en asie il en
resterait à peine 1000 ian barker
longtemps responsable du département de
chasse au kenya a constitué pour le
gouvernement américain
un énorme dossier sur la situation si
vous prenez par exemple le cas des
rhinocéros et bien les rhinos ont
pratiquement en voie d'extinction
c'est la crise pourquoi est-ce la crise
parce que les gouvernements africains
ont échoué ils n'ont pas réussi à faire
respecter la loi et il doit y avoir de
bonnes raisons pour cela et je ne crois
pas qu'on puisse régler la situation
dans l'immédiat bien sûr le nouveau
président affiche la volonté de lutter
contre la corruption
il a créé des unités spéciales qui
patrouillent dans les réserves
nous sommes partis avec l'une d'entre
elles mais il faut savoir qu'en afrique
du petit paysan jusqu'au dignitaires le
braconnage et pratique courant certains
disent aujourd'hui qu'en centrafrique
l'empereur bokassa par exemple organiser
des razzias avec l'armée on n'en est pas
là au kenya mais on constate quand même
que les enquêtes s'enlise souvent en
mars 79 les douanes ont saisi quatre
mille huit cents kilos d'ivoire et 141
une corne de rhinocéros
il n'y a pas eu d'arrestation mais la
corruption n'est pas le seul problème il
faut aussi faire face aux incursions des
troupes de nyéréré qui traînent en
ouganda et qui font parfois des
descentes du côté du lac turkana
ou bien des somaliens qui font de même
dans la région de savon
mais le principal ennemi des rhinocéros
est une tradition qui impose aux
yéménites du nord d'avoir un poignard
dans le manche est sculpté dans la
protubérance de l'animal 80% des animaux
qui sont tués le sont pour cette raison
la world wildlife fun association
mondiale de défense des animaux envisage
une seule solution est la seule chose
que lui ne pouvait faire c'est de
transférer les rhinocéros et les animaux
en danger dans une zone tu peux vraiment
être contrôlé c'est ce que notre
organisation envisage de faire car
contrôlé 34 1000 km² de réserves dans la
brousse n'est pas chose facile même si
le kenya et le mieux organisé des pays
africains quarante mille employés
s'occupent des parcs dont 500
effectivement sur le terrain au niger à
titre comparatif il y à un homme pour 58
mille kilomètres carrés
mais ce georges marchais bien de rentrer
ce soir d'un voyage à l'étranger qui l'a
conduit successivement à madagascar au
mozambique et au portugal
à son arrivée au bourget tout à l'air il
a répondu aux questions de nice breil
récit d'une de ses récentes
la france est sévèrement critiqué ou
plutôt la politique de monsieur giscard
d'estaing ce qui est tout à fait
différent la politique du chef de l'état
est critiquée par tous
les gouvernements qui voit son
intervention se multipliaient dans les
affaires intérieures des peuples ce qui
est du gabon au zaïre tchad centrafrique
récente décision avec le roi du maroc et
ses peuples qui veulent la réelle
indépendance qui veulent mettre un terme
au néo colonialisme ne peuvent pas
manquer des critiques à l'égard de la
politique du président de la république
c'est le premier aspect et le second
aspect c'est que en règle générale ces
peuples ces gouvernements y compris ceux
qui ont eu à souffrir du colonialisme
français souhaiteraient pouvoir
développer avec la france une
coopération à la fois économique
scientifique culturelle et politique
beaucoup plus importante que celle qui a
lieu actuellement
londres est devenu redevenue la capitale
européenne du théâtre toutes les formes
y sont présentes et représentées
en voici un exemple avec le théâtre pour
enfants qui a été inauguré récemment à
wimbledon dans la banlieue sud de
londres
philippe harrouard a passé une journée
au pôle cas théâtre
soyez les bienvenus au packaging iata
bonsoir
un théâtre dont le prince est un enfant
un royaume conçu pour lui consacrer à
lui est animé par lui ici on ne vient
pas en spectateur passif pour une somme
modique moins de 10 francs
les enfants passent toute la journée
dans ce pôle cas filter où ils auront
tant de choses à voir et à faire
et
mais
oui nous pensons dans ces années 80
qu'il ya trop de béton de verre de
saleté nous voudrions que les enfants
est une enfance magique disait de
merveilleuses jouets magiques qu'ils
entendent des histoires et des contes
les marionnettes de sont eux qui les
fabriquent
alors on commence par leur apprendre le
cola ils font appel à leur propre
imagination à leur inspiration
l'animatrice n'est là que pour les
conseiller techniquement
l'histoire de la marionnette il la
découvre dans le hall permanent
d'exposition
ce sont des chefs-d'oeuvre provenant du
monde entier qui ont fait rêver tant de
générations d'enfants
on
cette fois cela ne se passe pas au
cinéma
ou alors ce sont eux les acteurs
participer au théâtre c'est aussi bien
connaître son corps ses expressions ses
réactions
puis il pour se tremper dans le monde du
ministère de la magie et du rêve
leur monde elle interdit aux adultes
notre succès c'est que beaucoup
d'enfants viennent notre idée c'est
qu'ils aient un centre merveilleux
joliment décorée tout a été bâti et
décoré par le même salaire en plein
enthousiasme et quand ils reviennent
chez eux ou à l'école ils peuvent faire
un très bon travail
à partir de ce qu'ils ont vu une
douzaine d'animateurs se consacre depuis
dix ans à ce théâtre pour enfants
jusqu'à l'an dernier il effectué
uniquement des tournées en grande
bretagne depuis noël
ils ont pu créer ce lieu de rendez vous
permanent grâce à l'aide de l'état et de
mécène éclairé le pôle carte qui
attaquent pour enfants a même trouvé une
marraine très actives en la personne de
la reine mère elizabeth elle aura cet
été 80 ans un développement dans cette
dépêche en provenance de washington sur
ce que je disais tout à l'heure et la
décision du président carter celle
d'expulser et tous les diplomates
iraniens en poste aux états unis l'ordre
d'expulsion a été notifiée cet après
midi à l'ambassade d'iran à washington
où il reste un principe 35 diplomates
si vous venez de prendre notre émission
en cours de route je vous rappelle que
la décision du président carter a été
motivée par le fait que l'aïe appelle la
commune i a décidé qu'il n'y aurait
aucun changement dans la situation des
otages américains de l'ambassade
américaine à téhéran et que 1 plus tôt
c'est à la fin du mois de mai que le
parlement s'en occupe c'est un bien
curieux printemps que celui que nous
vivons on a l'impression que le temps
s'amuse à des paradoxes et n'est pas le
seul alors que dans le centre et le nord
de l'europe le soleil et quelques fois
présent rendez vous il fait mauvais dans
le sud de l'europe en sardaigne par
exemple et l'année g or la servane c'est
au sud de la côte
voyez et voilà qui nous amène tout droit
à la météo en france pour demain et bien
le matin il fera assez froid sur
l'ensemble du pays sur la moitié nord
temps nuageux avec pluies sur la moitié
sud
sauf quelques bancs de brouillard en
aquitaine il fera beau l'après-midi
sommeil sur les côtes de l'atlantique et
de la méditerranée
sur les autres régions nuages par
moments abondants avec des averses en
plaine et les chutes de neige en
montagne vent plus fort surtout sur la
mer du nord et dans la vallée du rhône
c'est hervé claude qui vous donnera les
dernières informations de la journée à
partir de 23 heures
il vous donnera notamment les dernières
dépêches en provenance de washington et
les rapports du tiercé que nous n'avons
pas encore demain n'oubliez pas antenne
2010 présenté par patrick lecocq avec
comme invité d'honneur
sa majesté le roi du maroc hassan ii
auquel jean pierre elkabbach paul nahon
et d'autres membres de la rédaction
d'antenne 2 poseront des questions
particulièrement intéressante
vous avez que le souverain vient de
passer quinze jours à paris qu'il a eu
des entretiens qualifiés d'importants
avec le président de la république puis
il s'est rendu à rome pour voir le pape
et de m'asseoir et bien ma foi à 20
heures vous retrouverez ici
patrick poivre d'un bonsoir merci